-Even as he tries
to refocus on trade policy,
Donald Trump's presidency
has been rocked this week
by escalating scandals
related to everything
from Russian meddling
to porn stars.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
On top of everything else
going on right now,
President Trump, of course,
is being sued
by porn star Stormy Daniels
over a reported hush payment
Trump's lawyer made to her
just weeks before the election
to hide an alleged affair.
The Trump White House
has insisted
that the accusations are false,
but last night,
we found out more about
the lengths to which Trump's
lawyer has gone
to silence Daniels.
-NBC News has learned that,
in late February,
the President's lawyer,
Michael Cohen secretly obtained
a temporary restraining order
against Daniels.
The order,
issued by a private arbiter,
bars Daniels from disclosing
confidential information
related to what her lawyer calls
a hush agreement
designed to keep Daniels quiet
about the intimate relationship
she's alleged to have had
with Mr. Trump.
-That's right -- The President
of the United States
got a restraining order
against a porn star,
which means we have to say
goodbye to the old
lowest point
in American history.
Goodbye, Garth Brooks'
rock-'n'-roll alter-ego
Chris Gaines!
[ Laughter ]
We hardly knew you!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And while that story
is developing,
Trump is also dealing
with the fallout
from the ongoing Russian probe,
which, not for nothing,
isn't a bad porn title.
[ Laughter ]
Now, there's a lot
that we don't know
about Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's investigation
of Trump's ties to Russia,
but one thing we do know
is that Trump
has been acting super guilty.
Trump has tried
to fire or coerce
almost everyone involved
in the Russia investigation
and refuses
to impose sanctions on Russia.
And yesterday,
we got yet another report
about Trump's
suspicious behavior.
Against the advice
of his lawyers,
Trump has been talking to
witnesses in the investigation
to find out
what they've been saying,
and Robert Mueller
found out about it.
-The Special Counsel
has learned of two conversations
in recent months
in which President Trump
asked key witnesses
about matters they discussed
with investigators.
-He asked witnesses
about their conversations
with investigators.
Trump looks
so guilty at this point,
even pictures of him have
shifty, haunted-mansion eyes.
[ Laughter ]
Now, as you might recall,
"The New York Times"
reported in January
that Trump had ordered
his White House counsel,
Don McGahn,
to fire Mueller,
which McGahn refused to do.
Now, according to
this new reporting,
the president told an aide that
McGahn should issue a statement
denying the "New York Times"
article in January.
But McGahn did not
publicly deny the article.
So, just to recap, Trump
told McGahn to fire Mueller,
but McGahn refused,
which got out.
So Trump told McGahn to deny
that he told him
to fire Mueller,
which McGahn again refused,
which then also got out.
Seriously, how are these two
still together?
Trump tells McGahn to do stuff,
McGahn says no,
it keeps getting in the press,
but Trump doesn't fire McGahn,
and McGahn doesn't quit.
They're like
one of those couples
that ruins every dinner party
by fighting,
and when they leave,
someone says,
"They must have amazing sex."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, we keep
getting more information
about the Trump team's ties
to Russians,
specifically their efforts
after the election
to set up a secret
communications channel
with the Kremlin.
Apparently, Mueller is now
homing in on Erik Prince,
founder of the mercenary company
Blackwater
and an adviser to
Trump's transition team.
Specifically, Mueller is now
looking at a secret meeting
Prince held with
a Kremlin emissary
on a remote island
shortly after the election.
-Robert Mueller has
"gathered evidence
that a secret meeting
in the Seychelles
just before the inauguration
of Donald Trump
was an effort to
establish a back-channel
between the incoming
administration and the Kremlin.
Erik Prince, the founder
of the private military
company Blackwater,
met with a Russian official
close to
President Vladimir Putin.
A witness cooperating with
Mueller has told investigators
the meeting was set up
in advance
so that a representative
of the Trump transition
could meet with
an emissary from Moscow
to discuss future relations
between the two countries."
-Wait. You're telling me
a secret meeting
on a remote island
in the Indian Ocean
between a mercenary
and an agent of the Kremlin
turned out to be suspicious?!
Where was the meeting --
inside a volcano
the shape of a skull?
-"We'll get down to business
shortly, gentlemen,
but, first,
enjoy your zebra steaks!
Orphans! Serve us!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, the meeting is of
special interest to Mueller
apparently because
Prince has lied about it.
He later told investigators
the meeting
was an unplanned encounter
that came about by chance
because he happened to be
at a luxury hotel
in the Indian Ocean
island nation
with officials from
the United Arab Emirates.
That's right. He tried to pass
it off as a chance encounter.
"I swear! I just happened to be
vacationing on a remote island
when I ran into a close friend
of Vladimir Putin.
Then -- silly me --
I got a paper cut on my hand.
And before you know it,
we were swearing a blood oath
and chanting "Hail Hydra."
It was just like one of those
Sandals commercials!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, by the way,
this isn't even the first time
the Trump team has tried
to set up a secret back-channel
with the Kremlin,
which, not for nothing,
isn't a bad porn title.
[ Laughter ]
Because last year,
as you may recall,
"The Washington Post"
broke the story
about the president's son-in-;aw
and senior adviser,
Jared Kushner.
-Jared Kushner and Russia's
ambassador to Washington
discussed the possibility
of setting up
a secret and secure
communications channel
between Trump's transition team
and the Kremlin.
-That's right --
Jared Kushner tried to set up
a secret communications channel
between the White House
and the Kremlin,
but unfortunately
he couldn't find a string
long enough to reach Moscow.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we don't know exactly
what came of all these attempts
to set up a secret back-channel,
but earlier this week,
we learned more about
what exactly the Kremlin may
have wanted from the Trump team,
when "The New Yorker"
published a blockbuster story
about ex-British spy
Christopher Steele.
He's the guy who wrote
that infamous dossier
about Trump's alleged ties
to Russia,
the one that contained those
salacious rumors about Trump.
Now, I can't tell you about
those rumors because
they are unverified,
but I don't need to because,
as we've documented
on this show before,
Trump wingman and Fox News host
Sean Hannity is all too happy,
for some reason,
to repeat the details
of this embarrassing allegation
over and over again on his show.
And with the Steele dossier
back in the news,
Trump supporter Sean Hannity
is at it again.
-Remember that's the dossier
that talked about Trump
at a Ritz-Carlton in Moscow
with two prostitutes
urinating on his bed?
The fake document
about President Trump,
and that goes
to the Ritz-Carlton,
and that goes to hookers.
That phony dossier
quoting Russians
and the Ritz-Carlton
and hookers.
That was about the Ritz-Carlton
You know, talking about hookers
and urinating in beds.
Hookers. Ritz-Carlton.
Urinating on a bed.
Russian, hookers.
Hookers. Hookers. Hookers.
Hookers urinating in his bed.
Peeing. Urinating. Urinating.
Urinating on beds. Wow!
Easy to laugh at the hookers
and the Ritz in Moscow.
Is that the funny part?
-No.
The funny part --
The funny part is that you
keep telling us about it.
The only way you could do more
to advertise this story
is if you took out
three billboards.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
This allegation was actually
back in the news this week,
thanks to ex-Trump
campaign aide Sam Nunberg,
who you may recall had
a meltdown on cable news
when he was called to appear
before a grand jury by Mueller.
Nunberg mentioned that Mueller
was interested in Trump's trip
to Moscow in 2013
for the Miss Universe Pageant.
Nunberg admitted that
a Russian associate offered
to send women
up to Trump's hotel room
but insisted that, according
to Trump's longtime bodyguard,
Keith Schiller,
Trump had rejected the offer.
-I was told that that idiot Emin
had offered to send women
up to Trump's room.
But Trump didn't want it.
-When you say, "I was told that
the Russians offered to send
women to Trump's room --"
-No. I was told that Emin
offered to send women up there.
And Trump flat-out refused it.
And Trump did
flat-out refuse it.
And I can tell you
that Trump is too smart
to have women
come up to his room.
-You think Donald Trump
is too smart to have women
come up to his room?
He's not even too smart
to not take a picture with them.
"Okay. Got that camera ready?
Everybody say...
exhibit A!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. But still...
Let's give Trump
the benefit of the doubt.
He might be an idiot,
but even he is too smart
to ever have women
up to his hotel room, right?
-In an interview published
tonight by "The Daily Beast,"
adult-film star Alana Evans
says she spoke with
Stephanie Clifford,
a.k.a. Stormy Daniels.
"She tells me,
'All I'm going to say
is I ended up with Donald
in his hotel room.
Picture him chasing me
around his hotel room
in his tighty-whities.'"
-No!
I don't want to picture that!
But, seriously, while
it's a terrifying thought
to picture Trump chasing you
in his tighty-whities,
the only way he'd ever catch you
is if you broke both ankles.
"Oh, no!"
"Enh! Come here!"
"Wait. Are you chasing me?"
"Enh! I'm gonna getcha!"
"I have to be honest --
you're moving so slowly,
I can't tell if you're
even getting closer."
"Ennhh..."
Okay, now, that was all
from the first Steele dossier,
but "The New Yorker"
reported this week
that Steele actually wrote
a second dossier
about the Trump transition
team's communications
with Russia after the election,
specifically about an alleged
attempt by the Kremlin
to block one of Trump's possible
picks for Secretary of State.
-Steele wrote another memo
back in November of 2016
in which a senior
Russian official relayed
talk circulating in the Russian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs
the Kremlin had intervened
to block Trump's
initial choice of Secretary
of State, Mitt Romney,
and that the Kremlin,
through unspecified channels,
had asked Trump to appoint
someone who would be prepared
to lift
Ukraine-related sanctions.
-That's right -- the Russians
allegedly intervened
to block Mitt Romney from being
Secretary of State,
which is a bummer for Romney
because he still had to have
dinner with Donald Trump.
Look at Romney's face.
That face is the physical
manifestation of this sound.
[ Womp-womp! ]
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump is swinging wildly
on policy,
he's being sued by a porn star,
and investigators are homing in
on his ties to the Kremlin.
And even his biggest supporters
seem to be mostly
interested in...
-Peeing. Urinating. Hookers.
-Which, not for nothing...
isn't a bad porn title.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]